welcome back to las vegas now in honor
of late actor paul walker's birthday
today we are getting fast and furious
here in las vegas now with his brother
cody co-founder of fuel fest the
world-class automotive experience where
fast and furious comes to life it is an
honor to have you on cody oh my gosh you
look just like paul
thank you so much for having me
thank you for being with us now um you
know this is the perfect way fuel fest
to honor your brother's legacy when did
you two fall in love with cars
at a young age i'm 15 years younger so
he had a huge impact on my life ever
since i was a little kid
dad always had something cool in the
garage too and so i just
i didn't have a choice
it's just a part of your makeup there
and you know obviously fuel fest is on
october 22nd on the las vegas motor
speedway you guys just had a sold out
crowd and the biggest japan car event in
tokyo can you talk about that experience
we did i just gotta say i'm so proud of
the entire team and everybody that helps
make this show possible but yeah we had
an insane show at fuji's international
speedway in japan um just last month it
was a sold out show
and uh it was just it was amazing just
races all day long incredible cars the
culture there is just wild and uh it was
amazing amazing show so cool if you
can't be there you just watch fasting
for your tokyo drift right
that's right we had sung out there too
who of course plays han
he's like a brother to me he came out to
the show as well in japan and we just
blew it up together had so much fun
doing it that is so cool now let's bring
it over now to las vegas october 22nd
what can we expect on the speedway
you know this is a celebration of car
culture and i think most people know a
car show but it's so much more than a
car show right so we have of course like
performance-built cars and drag racing
cars and exotic cars but we also have
live action all day long we have
drifting all day long we have a top 16
drift competition and if you just come
in you know general admission you want
to just check things out and have a good
time we have pro drift drivers that you
can ride in their car with in new
ride-alongs on the drift course oh my
gosh dreams
it is so much fun that's so cool and
lastly here we have a few more seconds i
want to get to this benefits the i'm
sorry the reach out worldwide foundation
explain that yes no that's that's that
was the whole reason of creating fuel
fest uh reach out worldwide is a charity
that paul founded
going on 13 years ago we're all very
very proud of it and this is just a fun
way to create awareness for the
organization we've raised uh over 160
000 for charity at this point and we're
just going to keep going because we're
just they they say do what you love i
love this
and also have that element just makes it
all that much more special so seeing
everybody come out and just to see all
the support is just amazing and we're
looking forward to celebrating with
everybody uh in vegas on october 22nd
wow that is so cool thank you so much
cody for everything you're doing keeping
your brother's legacy alive too happy
birthday to him
yeah happy birthday to him thank you so
much for having me thank you cody fuel
fest is coming to las vegas motor
speedway october 22nd for more
information just visit fuelfest.com jc i
know you like that